well as the slide says the internet of
everything is inevitable so i'll spend a
few slides trying to argue why that's
true
everything that comes out of my mouth
is suspect so you should be extremely
skeptical about anything that i say but
here are some plots that were
constructed by other people so you can
blame them if you don't want to believe
them but you know we've cut the court
it's not you know clearly i'm stating
the obvious here we're a mobile species
now but when that happened was fairly
recently it turns out that sometime in
december of 2001 the number of
subscribers to wireless services finally
exceeded the number of subscribers to
wireline services that happened only 13
years ago about this month that's
amazing so we suddenly became a mobile
species at that time now of course today
it's an amazing achievement that we've
collectively done as a species we've
managed to sell four million cell phones
to you every day
that's amazing to me that that number
just staggers me uh and we use this
wonderful technology this miracle of
modern science to exchange 250 000
completely content-free text messages
every second
hooray for technology it's wonderful
so
already there are more than 6 billion
mobile subscriptions out of a population
on the earth of 7 billion humans so
essentially everyone with the power to
communicate is able to communicate
in 1981 there were zero so that's a
pretty fast ramp up in one human
generation we go from zero to
essentially connecting everyone in a
mobile fashion
this year we're projected to actually
have the number of subscriptions exceed
the global population because some
people have more than one phone business
and home
that's an astounding statistic
that means that we really don't have
more markets to expand into essentially
the only untapped market is babies
and i'm sure there's some marketing
genius and some companies somewhere
figuring out how to connect babies to
the net uh it's coming i'm only half
joking i saw a little pop-up recently on
a twitter feed that there is a company
trying to get babies to tweet to their
parents somehow
god help us all all right
now it's interesting to take a look at
the historical path that led to the
present because we might be able to
extract some lessons from that history
to guess maybe at some possible futures
so it turns out that we can divide the
history of communications into three
broad ages the first age of wireless was
given to us by marconi who's often given
the title inventor of radio but if you
take a look at what marconi actually did
he gave us station to station wireless
telegraphy using spark equipment you
could not send the voice it was just
morse code dots and dashes but it was
transformative because it allowed for
the first time ships to communicate with
each other and with a shore i mean it's
hard to imagine today with our 24 7
connectivity but it wasn't that long ago
when you embarked on an ocean voyage you
were lost to the world until you reached
the other side or
passed another ship
so marconi's telegraph changed all of
that
and it was amazing thing it famously
enabled the rescue of the titanic
survivors in 1912
but because it was a station to station
service and because you had to use this
goofy morse code it wasn't a personal
telecommunications device you had to hop
on a horse and go to the station give
them a message and some nerd would tap
it out in worse code and the inverse
operation happened on the receiver side
and so that limited the reach to serve
the kilo scale but it was important
the second age of wireless
occurred kind of by accident now the
reason i
the reason i show this picture is
because it shows that there is one
constant in humans and that is the geek
gene
is
has not undergone any mutations you know
i'm sure that back in the paleozoic era
there was some guy said i got this thing
called the wheel it's a really cool
thing and it's you know bothered all of
his friends about the wheel and his many
characteristics well here's a guy who
was sort of the modern version of the
wheel edwin howard armstrong he's on his
honeymoon for god's sake
uh and there's his wife saying oh my god
i married this guy uh he's twiddling the
knobs on the first portable am radio
and it's portable only in the sense that
there's a handle on it
much as my suv is portable because i put
a handle on it it's the same sort of
idea here
but it shows a beautiful sign of what
occurred around the 1920s
when the morse telegraph thing of
marconi
morphed into this thing where you had a
single station
reaching out to potentially millions of
listeners broadcasting
was unprecedented there was nothing
similar to it that had preceded in fact
the word broadcasting had to be stolen
from farmers where it still means the
spreading of seeds
anytime engineers are stealing language
from farmers tells you that the
phenomenon occurred so fast that they
were just struggling for verbiage to
describe what was already in motion
and so broadcasting was unexpected it
displaced marconi he kind of fades from
the stage of history at that point and
startups like nbc and cbs start minting
money with advertising a model that
seems to succeed well into the internet
age
the third age of wireless is what we're
enjoying today people-to-people
connectivity
we now go from the the mega scale reach
of broadcasting to the giga scale that
we enjoy today you can call anyone on
the planet anytime you want 24 7 you
don't even think about the cost anymore
except the parents who are paying their
children's bills and uh and and so we've
got this six billion people connected
out of the 7 billion on the planet it's
amazing so you say this is glorious
we're actually done with history we've
connected everybody up with this amazing
resource we can find out anything that
we want to find out when we want to find
out about it
it's an amazing thing now
the picture isn't entirely rosy
especially if you're say at t or verizon
or any of the service providers who have
built up all this technology at great
capital expense
one of the trends
that is somewhat worrisome to some folks
is that voice revenue is dropping like a
rock while data is going up and the cost
of supporting this is very high
and it turns out that these two curves
crossed over sometime in the middle of
last year a much unremarked upon i think
apoc making event where for the first
time we became a net mobile digital
species
and i think future historians will have
a lot to say about the meaning of that
particular crossover
if you look at this curve you get really
frightened because the revenue from new
subscriptions has plummeted essentially
to zero because again we've connected
everybody who has the ability to speak
so
there aren't new markets to conquer and
yet we're constantly demanding
us as customers we're constantly
demanding more services faster data
rates i want to download the entire
season of game of thrones in three
seconds on my phone and even though our
brains are not evolving to be
exponentially faster to consume the data
nevertheless it doesn't ever stop us
so
i argue that all of these vectors point
to the existence of a fourth age which
actually has already happened it's
already started
we're going to add objects to the
conversation that will enable us to now
go from the mega scale to the giga scale
to the terra scale we're going to
connect a trillion devices in the next
say 20 years so just make up a number
that's far enough in the future that
i'll be retired by then so you can't
come back and say hey you were wrong so
it's not just an internet of things
which is something that people have been
talking about for some time it's
actually the internet of everything it's
people interacting with objects as well
as objects interacting with other
objects and the architectures of these
connections will be
webs of webs nets of nets nets of webs
any of mixture that you can imagine
connecting all these things whatever
makes sense
will take place
now
if you are willing to accept
the assumption that we're going to
connect a trillion devices someday if
you're willing to allow me to be insane
because you have no choice
then you have to look at what sort of
things have to occur between now and
that glorious future to make that future
possible one of the things is somebody's
got to design a trillion devices
we have to manufacture them
um take some percentage of a trillion
devices to figure out how many unique
designs are implied by that number and
no matter what percentage you choose you
exceed the number of engineers on the
planet
so we have a limitation right there
there's a bottleneck and just an
insufficiency of engineers now one
solution that stanford is very well
poised to to solve this just convert
more people in engineers but there's a
limit to even stanford's ability to to
make that happen we have the
neurobiologist working on how to
reconfigure brains and everything else
to make that you know also i want to be
an engineer yes
but again we think there's a limit to
how many of those we can actually
convert
another problem is
even a small fraction of a trillion
devices probably can't be battery
powered
environmentally it's not going to happen
and humans just aren't going to tolerate
having to replace batteries and
thousands of devices every year i mean
for guys sakes my you know smoke
detector doesn't get attention as often
as it should so a thousand devices
around my house they're all just going
to be beeping at me until they stop
beeping
so
that's one problem we have to solve
another one is if you have a trillion
devices all interconnected just think
about what that implies already
technology has insinuated itself into
the very fabric of civilization in such
a profound way that we can't imagine
life without it well now we're talking
about going another order of magnitude
or three
of that sort of insinuation that means
now we become so dependent on this
ubiquitous technology that that
constitutes a potential risk to
civilization it constitutes a large
attack surface what about security what
about privacy what about coronal mass
ejections from the sun that wipes out
electrical stuff we have to worry about
these things now when we talk about
deploying electronics on this vast scale
so
the i'm a glass is half full kind of guy
and so i look at these i go wow this is
more fun stuff for my students to work
on for the next 10 20 years it's
fantastic now of course if you're a
glasses half full empty kind of person
you say oh wow this you know will be the
end of us all
it's somewhere in between those two
things so
now what are some possible solutions
these are some of the ideas that we're
exploring now and and uh professor
horowitz will talk about some of these
in his talk
uh automated design tools as a workforce
multiplier can help bridge the gap so
that instead of having
a small number of humans try to design a
small number of devices we can have that
small number of humans multiply their
effectiveness thanks to computer aided
design tools that are another another
level of sophistication above where they
currently reside
we talk about maybe building a device
that has the ability to be programmed
after it's been manufactured so that you
can have individualized functionality
that essentially involves a software
exercise as opposed to pure
manufacturing exercise and i'm calling
this just as a placeholder a field
programmable things array so you build
lots of fptas you can pump them out like
jelly beans and chocolate chip cookies
and at the end you can have makers as
well as
ordinary industry personalize these
things to have specific functions out of
them
now how about about the battery problem
well there's lots of research ongoing at
stanford as well as elsewhere in
so-called energy harvesting kinds of
ideas where you can pull
power out of the sun out of thermal
differences out of vibration and so
forth and i'm sure that will be part of
the solution but it's probably not by
itself going to be sufficient to enable
a compelling swath of applications
so we're now investigating the
possibility of using the same base
stations that you use to connect to your
cell phone network also to beam power to
these devices so we're going to use
remote
powering by wireless sort of the dream
of tesla
and
to address the security aspects we're
going to have to do some more work on
encryption engines on security engines
and since security threats tend to
evolve it's a spy counter spy kind of
thing you're never done
uh we'll probably have to have it be
flexible in some some way so we can
upgrade the security engines once we
built them
otherwise we'll have to replace a
trillion devices every single time a new
threat emerges out in the field so there
are lots of good hard problems to work
on i don't think any of these is
fundamentally insoluble it just requires
a lot of really bright people
to work on these things and solve them
so here's some ideas here and you can
tell that i'm uh very gifted at art here
so we have a 5g cell tower here powering
up these things
with power and looking at the data that
comes back and and pinging them with
data and then you'll have some
smartphone that also can communicate
with a tower and perhaps directly with
the things if they're very nearby don't
have to necessarily hop all the way to
the base station and back out again so
there's an architecture here that can
get rid of the batteries now in terms of
the power levels we're not going to be
able to power up a buick but we'll be
able to power up little devices that
sense things maybe take some video shots
measure temperature those kinds of
things that can be done on milliwatt
power scales and that's something that's
very comfortably deployed and conveyed
with a 5g tower kind of idea
what are some of the applications i'll
be honest here i don't know what are
going to be the killer apps i don't
think anyone really knows but i think
it's going to be somewhere in here
because i've shotgunned just about the
entire space of all things that one
would ever want to do
you want to use your cell phone perhaps
as a remote control to open your garage
door to sense temperature to adjust
temperature i'm the kind of nervous
nelly that as soon as i hop on a plane
to go to conference i
did i close the garage door did i leave
the lawn sprinkler on darn it i don't
really know i would love to just be able
to pull up a smartphone and look at it
and it tells me right away oh yes i did
leave the garage door open press close
it closes i would love to be able to do
that so people who just like to track
things obsessively
that would be a great thing to have
of course you would like to access
content for various things
i definitely would like to have a
complete monitoring facility in my house
so i know when my water heater is
starting to drip
so before it floods my basement i've
already got an early warning and in fact
it's already called the plumber and the
plumber has sent me an email saying hey
i'm going to be in the neighborhood and
then your water heater is leaking you
want me to just stop by and fix it
fantastic go do that so i would love to
have those sorts of early warning signs
uh just taken care of invisibly without
my having to take any real action just
have to respond to a request that's
already pushed to me
so these are the sorts of things that
are going to happen
your smartphone will become the
dashboard and the remote control for
everything in your life that you care to
track and that you care to worry about
healthcare is another huge opportunity
here we're in the century where i think
future historians will say wow this is
the century where bio met electrical
engineering and fantastic things
happened and among those will be you'll
be able to monitor your health more or
less constantly i think it's crazy that
you see your doctor maybe once or twice
a year and based on that tiny sampling
window they try to infer something about
the state of your health i think it's
crazy
it'd be nice to be able to get a
continuous monitoring of all the vital
stats establish a baseline and when
there's a delta from your baseline it
triggers some action it contacts your
healthcare provider say hey why don't
you come in for a full workup cause
there's something kind of weird going on
with you know your t2 hormones or
something so
an example of what might be able to
happen to enable that there's a company
that's manufacturing i think this is
just fda approved this year
a pill that you swallow
and it's actually activated by your
battery acid your stomach acid your
stomach acid is
your stomach acid is the electrolyte for
the battery that powers this thing up
and if it doesn't power up that itself
is a sign that there's something
seriously wrong with you
so
once it powers up it starts beaming data
through your body and to a little vest
that you wear that communicates with it
and aggregates the data and then beams
it to your health care provider so i
love the idea that we'll now have these
of disposable electronics that will
monitor important things about your
health that's a great idea
qualcomm and other companies have
recognized the potential opportunities
here i've just shown this from a
qualcomm x prize announcement where
they're sponsoring a 10 million dollar
prize to incentivize people to think
about how to convert a cell phone
someday into our best approximation to
the star trek tricorder you know bones
just waves this at you and tells you oh
you got cancer but i just fixed it by
pressing the green button
and everything is really good now so
that's for the individual level having
come from darpa where we worry about
global effects it also can be useful to
know something about
yes the internet of things is talking to
me
it's already happened so
the dystopian future has arrived
but massive data collects if we can
somehow scrub the data of any personal
linkage so that we just get data about
what's happening in a neighborhood
suppose all of a sudden we discover that
lots of people in one neighborhood are
heading to walmart for anti-diarrheals
that might be a sign that there's a bad
restaurant in the neighborhood and you
might be able to kind of triangulate
where the center is or maybe something
more sinister has occurred to the air or
the water supply in the neighborhood you
kind of like to have an early warning of
that going on and amount to a correct
response to that so there's all sorts of
global effects that we might be able to
extract out of networked intelligence of
this kind
so
i think there are all sorts of
interesting features of course not all
of them will be glorious you know
suppose you have a home automation logic
that decides to get cranky you might
have an exchange like this and hal tells
you i'm sorry dave i can't do that
we've seen that in a movie somewhere i
think but uh you know sometimes movies
are more prophetic than we want to admit
i think again a lot of the value will
come not from the things themselves but
the data that generate and the data that
they share in aggregate with all the
other nodes and i think there will be a
huge value add
from just that data
now
one of the pushbacks that i often get is
yeah but you know can it ever really get
that big you know can you really scale
to the terra scale that just sounds
nutty
well
i just point out
some stats the semiconductor business is
300 billion dollars a year
the weight loss industry just in the
united states is 60 billion a year 20 of
that
so i i think there's enough fungibility
here
to make that in fact if we just can
convince people that if they ate silicon
they would lose weight
and have better complexions i think
right there we've we've gone you know
pretty much all the way to the future so
uh we're working on this right now we
have our top people working on it
uh so in terms of what's the future
gonna look like hell i don't know uh but
we're gonna but here's some
possibilities that people have stood up
as
good straw men proposals this one
clearly came from a satellite company
because everything communicates to a
satellite
somehow i don't think that's the way the
future but satellites will be around but
i don't think that's the way we're gonna
go
i think lockheed probably built this one
uh
cars are very interesting opportunity
already 40 of the value in a car comes
from electronics and it's increasing and
i think that we're going to find
wireless networks within cars
to allow various accessories to talk to
each other and then allow cars to talk
to other cars and to base stations i
think this is coming already your cars
are instrumenting a lot of things about
your engine's health it'd be nice if
they could now network that data back to
the home planet and say you know what
you know you got a misfire in cylinder
three why don't you bring it in for
some remediation we'll fix that right up
and get your gas mileage back up to
where it belongs i think all these
things are going to happen and there are
lots of you type in internet of things
into google and out will pop millions
and millions of white papers and slides
uh you know promising you glorious
futures and various other things and you
know please buy our stuff sorts of
messages you're used to that
so if you take a look at all the stuff
in aggregate take a look at the vectors
that history is pointing to you take a
look at all the things that we might be
able to do that's of value to us that we
recognize now and then sort of take a
leap of faith that smart people will
figure out even better things to do with
it than we've been able to identify now
i think that you must conclude that the
future
is extremely bright so thank you for
your forbearance and
talk to you later